all right it's time for this week's sin
city chronicles a weekly look back at
vegas history and happenings
and let's start with the release of one
of the most iconic movies
about our city
[Music]
viva las vegas starring elvis presley
and anne margaret was released in may of
1964.
the song and dance movie was a hit at
the box office it cost 1 million to make
and made close to 10
million dollars so on may 24th 1955 the
mullin rouge opened
it was the nation's first racially
integrated casino
the casino was only open for six months
but in that time it was an
entertainment mecca all of the great
stopped in including
sammy davis jr louis armstrong nat king
cole
judy garland frank sinatra there were so
many entertainers stopping by
that management added a third show at
2am to accommodate the crowds
you can see the casino's iconic sign at
the neon museum
the dunes hotel and casino opened on may
23 1955
the miracle in the desert had an 18-hole
golf course
a rooftop spa and became the first hotel
to have a topless show
it came down in 1993 and the bellagio
now stands in its place
right may 29 1994 was the end of an
era
error
[Music]
[Applause]
frank sinatra performed his last concert
in las vegas at the mgm grand
he performed 14 songs that night
frank's final song was this one new york
new york
sinatra passed away in 1998
that voice may 21st 1991
whitney houston's i'm your baby tonight
tour was at the thomas and mack
now houston performed close to 100
concerts that year
but vegas was extra special because
prior to the show
the crowd was treated to an unplanned
on-stage appearance
to mike tyson something that whitney
houston
was not happy about and that's your
cincinnati chronicles for the last week
of may